when I grow up I want to be the first
person to teleport himself even if you
could build it I've already built it is
it next to your flying car I'm not
working on that angle
read your insane thanks
it is our duty as human beings to push
forward into the unknown
but sometimes
you're looking to discover one thing
and you find something else
just one fix my friends
we can't change the past
but we can change the future how I need
a heat-resistant workshop and a big ass
son they are dangerous and powerful
which makes them extremely valuable to
the government you promised me you
wouldn't use my kids as weapons
you see me mad power and do you you
don't know anything about what's going
what is coming dude
this is our chance to make a difference
poor family if we do this we do it our
way what if we say no say yes
this is the end of your world
beginning of mine
older than any of us
he's not stronger than alders
dr. stone we are means x yahoo million
from talaga game z on studying garnets
bus is yet to end us Reed Richards